Fatima is a cutter she has a handful of
instruments but her main tool is a razor
blade how sharp is it can she show us
that's what she uses to slice off female
genitalia a brutal mutilation which the
Somali region of Puntland is trying to
outlaw most of the girls here Fatima's
already cut that's how she's made her
living it's a job which until now has
been seen as an honorable one
she'll even cut her relatives and these
her two little granddaughters does she
hope to eventually do them
Fatima demonstrates for us how she
carries out the procedure a little girl
willingly takes part in this show
they're typically held down by relatives
and conditioned to believe it's a
privilege a rite of passage she shows us
how they sometimes cover their faces to
stifle the screams
despite the region's attempts a law
banning FGM has yet to be discussed or
passed in Puntland's parliament so
cutters like fatima are still very much
in business she explains why the girls
are cut so young usually between the
ages of six and ten and her explanation
is telling so Cassio is the optimum age
she's seven years old and Cassio is not
her real name
after much prompting from the older
women Cassio insists she wants to be cut
people will be like a shame for me so if
and leave with Indus come we try to get
her mother to reconsider but with around
five other circumcisions going on in
nearby homes she insists she's doing
what's necessary is there anything that
would persuade you not to circumcise
your daughter why not what why is there
nothing that would persuade her as she's
so determined the circumcision theater
today is the family's tin shack home and
the older women think he feels lucky
she'll be injected with local
anaesthetic that they never had before
the razor blade was wielded the cutter
already has the needle threaded to
stitch her up almost entirely closed so
her future husband will know she is a
virgin we've decided not to show you
what happens next inside our appeals
were met with laughter we're doing the
best for our daughter they said it takes
less than half an hour to change
Cassio's body forever when it's done the
cut is celebrated and her legs are bound
to keep the stitches in place it'll
remain for a week our team reported this
to the police but with no law in place
it's impossible to act and most still
don't understand what's wrong with it to
be happy and then have fun with girls
and then to tell that uncircumcised and
she should be proud
the maternity hospital in Garraway is
full of women suffering from the cut
years later Rajas baby was born a few
hours ago by cesarean because she
couldn't deliver normally can I know how
she feels towards her mother for
allowing my mother did this because of
ignorance number one she did this
because her great mother did this to her
but me that since I know
the complication is I will try to cut
this cycle does she have any lasting
resentment towards her mother because
her mother's would know about the
complications to what she did for me to
me
her aunt who's listening takes issue
with that she's helped with dozens of
cuttings the community will not accept
uncircumcised girl nobody will come and
marry her in the next ward zina is
recovering from her sixth stillborn baby
because of the difficulties caused by
the childhood circumcision she has just
one six year old daughter who she will
have circumcised too if you've had the
choice would you have had it
[Music]
while ago say now is she say now she's a
married woman with one living child if
not circumcision she wouldn't have a
mantle Maria the problems after
circumcision start almost immediately
chakra was sewn up so completely her
bodily functions were agonizing and she
swiftly got infections she'll now have
to have surgery but despite this being
the only option so she can actually pass
urine as well as cope with her menstrual
cycle she doesn't want it because she
fears alienation in her community I'm
worried the other girls will bully me
after the operation she says because
they'll know I'm not circumcised her
mother feels horribly guilty and there's
a suspicion the family will end up
having the little girls circumcised
twice Zahra two was cut twice and still
the problems went on it's a lifelong
trauma I'm getting married I get a
pretty pregnant then I afraid how to
deliver the baby I have you envy you
they will cut you you know what they
closed they will cut again can I a
frayed afraid but alhamdulillah I don't
then I get only one baby it's an issue
which goes to the very top of this
deeply conservative society the woman
known as the first lady of Puntland is
not alone in denouncing the practice as
very Una's la m'q she's caused quite a
stir by spearheading a campaign to have
FGM banned the presidential
determination to end these cultural
traditions is deeply personal
years old I participated in getting the
things that needed to be used because I
thought everybody was doing it all the
girls like my age had to go through it
so that's just if you don't do it then
things change many many years later we
learn it's not it's just a tradition
tradition is just but even in Burton Lee
town where they've introduced zero
tolerance to FGM it's hard to enforce
especially when the procedure has been a
source of cash for so many other
community the first lady explained what
they've been telling her they don't do
it anymore but what happened is that we
have no life LaHood's we have no jobs
there's no alternative livelihoods so
we're stuck now where support and even
if the women are persuaded there's a lot
of work to be done on the men about
female circumcision I just want to ask
them how they feel about marrying a
woman who is not circumcised women
should be circumcised in line with the
Islamic sharia I wanted to marry and
even though religious leaders in
Portland issued a joint decree speaking
out against all forms of cutting some
clerics are still preaching that partial
genital cutting is good there are things
that Islam says have to be done cutting
nails cutting the clitoris and cutting
pubic hair but Puntland's first lady and
a slew of worldwide bodies insists
that's simply wrong
it's barbaric and not a Quranic ruling
at all you would still have a lot of
people who are misinformed about the the
program the practice which they think
that the garrulous Valley and
and cleanness really depends to be
circumcised and mutilated and cut but
that's that's really not in any way you
can explain it is very uncivilized and
it has no basis in religion it has no
base in in human rights but the
president's people are going to take
some convincing in a few weeks time this
little four-year-old will be circumcised
along with her older sister one of
hundreds of girls mutilated every day in
this country
Alix Crawford Sky News and Puntland
Somalia